je l'appelais lucie carrasco je suis
handicapé je suis en fauteuil roulant et
la société turque sirène refusé de me
prendre à bord de son avion pour cause
de handicap trop imposant je m'appelle
naomi je suis l'auxiliaire de vie de lui
si donc j'étais aussi le présente pour
le vol en direction de turquie ce qui
vient de se passer est lié avec autant
de d'agressivité d'une discrétion je
n'ai jamais vécu ça lundi 2 mai je vais
prendre mon vol vers 11h35 à l'aéroport
de lyon-saint-exupéry
moi j'ai j'ai bouquet donc d ici à deux
spéciaux une assistance spéciale pour
être accompagnés jusqu'à l'avion et j'ai
même payer un supplément pour avoir des
sièges en plus des espaces au niveau des
jambes je croirais d'abord on nous
répondait devant des sièges réservés
quant aux numéros correspondaient mais
le siège de course on n'est pas du tout
excusez-moi j'ai réservé des sièges ne
correspondent pas elle en dit vous
montrer son réel c'est tout bon s'est
fait agresser et leurs élections ne
devraient pas hésiter à ne pas essayer
parce que sa place pas son fort et hyper
mal et alors ce sera cependant un
problème où j'arrivais à faire du
collège fois fou et il s'avère on
apprend que ça devait être un autre
avion sur lesquels avaient réservé des
places qui convenait et la cus a indiqué
les avions qui a été remplacé à la bombe
ont fait flop mon père y ait eu des
bombes sous fond de l'avion et moi je
leur montrais mes passagers
en ont et tout au fond
et de mecs de résistance mais aéroports
sowaer là on hallucine ils ont eu la
gentillesse de nous proposer trois
sièges l'un à côté de l'autre nous avons
dit que ce n'était pas possible parce
que les pièces ne pourrait tout de même
pas rentrer et c'est à ce moment là qui
nous a proposé de la coucher sur le
siège pour prendre les sièges en
longueur de tests 10 mais en vrai à
mettront be nice on a deux personnes sur
une vingtaine de sièges vous avez deux
personnes auront décidé au moins cinq
ans pas de moi c'est au dessus et si on
veut pas en entendre parler vous
descendez donc préférez faire prendre
plus d'une heure de retard
récupérez vos affaires en soute et nous
faire sortir tout de même sur un siège
qui correspond
en sort est là pour terminer
l'humiliation car dd aime ou pas ça qui
ont raté leur correspondance de plestan
grube maintenant c'est ça va c'est à
cause de ses trois aires
donc en rond je pense qu'on aurait jeté
des pierres s'étaient même chose on part
un peu un peu speed et les hommes
l'agent d'assistance pmr
tuberculose était surpris qu'un manuel
comme je disais le bruch ma poule
dimanche avec les épreuves sur les
oreilles et avait un petit sac devant et
un prix gonflé et faux départ c'est en
avant avec moi sur ma tête s'est
rapproché du sol et j'ai fait un coup du
lapin dans la nuque d'un seul coup tout
se mélange dans ma tête
j'ai rendez vous là on à peu près
ailleurs on devrait atterrir à istanbul
g1taxi d'adapter jouer à temps j'ai des
rendez vous professionnels ce matin que
chaque cuvée les dommages et de me
dédommager pour le préjudice personnel
direct au niveau du travail au niveau du
taxi on every you tell et je me suis pas
présenté à la barre que même si
maintenant sûrs d'être remboursés aux
boycotteurs on vous rembourse à l'achat
mais on savait que rennes ne vous
donnera pas un euro pour rembourser
d'autres vous n'avez pas nous faire une
crise pour un dieu pour les faire du
tourisme à istanbul parce qu'on est
handicapé ne travaille pas en guerre et
paix l'état pur et ça qu'ils jugent de
la vocation à voyager avec quoi ils
prenaient moi c'est pas une passion de
la gendarmerie pour répondre mais je
vais devoir le faire parce qu'il faut
aussi peut-être dire que mon cas n'est
pas isolé depuis qu'il est arrivé ça
j'ai fait une petite vidéo qui a
beaucoup tourné et je reçois des
centaines de témoignages de personnes
qui se sont fait géré également parce
que les terrains du cap est de mise avec
des enfants ont fait les santé enfants
chabanon vous prévoyez de quoi c'est pas
complété ne vous reproduisez pas des
gens qui sont la loue des situations
aberrantes que je sens qu'on va raconter
malheureusement ça arrive tous les jours
et pourrait avoir beaucoup voyagé
notamment pour mes documentaire pour
france 5
c'est terrible c'est à dire ça n'arrive
qu'en france